but you know you kind of alluded to
cancer culture there i grew up in an era
of massive cancer culture and it was uh
progressives who got cancelled so i
remember sending a tape into a minnesota
radio station and then the program
director was decent enough to call me
back and said this is fantastic and he's
like and i'm like all right great what
time slot do you have available and he's
like none i said why he said you're on
the left all of my other programming is
on the right so i'm not going to count a
program in the middle of the day
so you know good luck to you kid because
you're really good what year was that
90s that was we had already started on
serious and they were allowing us to
pitch it to other radio stations so that
was around 2003. yeah i mean cancel
culture hurts both sides it's not just
one set of some it's it flip-flops
though it goes one side for 10 20 30
years and then whoever's in charge then
it goes to the other side then it goes
to the other side either way we just
want to hear people's arguments yeah and
let us let us as the viewer make a
decision what's right and what's not
yeah i i think that there is one clear
line for sure there's an arguable second
line but advocating for violence is
unacceptable okay so that's my clear
line and so other than that i've
defended ben shapiro and coulter when
they're giving speeches on college
campuses i didn't think megyn kelly or
don imus or any of those people should
have been fired you s it doesn't serve
anyone to fire people it doesn't serve
the nation it doesn't serve the
conversation why don't you like when
megan kelly made the comments about um
black or white santa claus or whatever
it was that uh no in in the nbc case it
was blackface right
um she had made the comments about santa
claus when she was on fox so nbc fires
her right obviously they were just doing
that because the ratings weren't working
out and they want to dump the contract
that's keeping it real right but
if they were serious and they were just
outraged at that suggestion which is
preposterous honestly then why don't you
have al roker who was really mad about
it and and other people come on and have
a national conversation with megyn kelly
that way people will learn why blackface
is offensive instead of not having any
idea all they know is people just
randomly get fired right what about
putting whoopi on two week time out
because she had some unsavory thoughts
yeah that was
absolutely absurd now having said that i
still think today a majority of the
cancer culture is on the right wing it
started on the right wing it's still in
the right wing it's still in the right
yes absolutely how did it start how can
you say so the modern cancer culture
started with barry weiss which is
hilarious and ironic she went around the
country getting famous for trying to
fire professors who dare to talk about
palestinian human rights so if they said
palestinians were equal and should have
their own state she would try to get
them fired okay and so she started
canceled culture what year was that so
that was that's a good question
about 20 years ago i think without wrong
new york times what was she
no no it was before she was at the new
york times that's how she got famous
that's how she got friends they're not
pro-israel enough fire and fire and fire
you can look it up okay so she starts
cancer culture then she pretends that
she's a victim of it which by the way
she never was she was never fired from
anywhere she decided to quit the new
york times to make more money on her own
so look
the
what are the right ways you can't say
behind closed doors you can't write this
you can't do this i mean that stuff
happens just like it happened to you
when you're over there saying you got to
talk more like a senator you get
whatever word they use with your
senatorial when you're speaking like oh
it's editorial right so that kind of
stuff is probably what you know rob
heard the wrong way if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]